that moment is kind of ridiculous we
shot that in like the the mountains
outside of like uh Asheville in North
Carolina there were a ton of snakes and
like they put me into like a rock
crevice that just looked like it went
infinitely back into like a dark snake
pit so I was I had to lay there for like
45 minutes while they did this whole
makeup thing on the face I didn't see
what it looked like cuz it was on me and
I didn't see a monitor or anything so I
saw playback after like when they were
showing me what it looked like and uh I
couldn't stop laughing cuz I was was
like how did he pull this off like with
what they were like he's a baker I'm
like yeah cool but like that's crazy
they're like it works I'm like all right
I'm just I'm just an actor I I'll shut
up but you know it's kind of kind of
crazy